I am standing in the middle of the al-
magazi refugee camp for months it's been
reeling under ruthless bombardment by
the Israeli war planes and
bombing it was then invaded by the
Israeli tanks and
troops I'll show you the scale of
Destruction and the extent of damage all
over the
area I'll start with this residential
building behind me it belongs to the
alhaj household it was shelled this
morning as the Israeli carpet bombing
continues a woman and all her children
were killed their bodies still buried
under the
debris many residents left the area and
others fled South and others returned as
they had nowhere to go there's no safe
place in the Gaza
Strip I'll speak to the owner who
miraculously survived the
strike tell us what
happened since the start of the war the
Israeli war planes and artillery have
been carpet bombing all over the strip a
month ago the Israeli soldiers invaded
the area they destroyed what the war
planes hadn't including the mosques my
two sons were killed then about 5:00
a.m. this morning my home and my
brothers which is just next to me were
shelled and
leveled so two residential homes
belonging to the alhaj family were
destroyed
yes a while ago my two sons were
killed the Elder was married with a
family of four this morning their
cousin's wife with all their children
were killed the father was injured and
lying at hospital because of the
intensity of the strike some of the dead
bodies were knocked through the air
Unfortunately they just returned home
yesterday I wasn't there
myself make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer